une première depuis 50 ans les 700
élèves du lycée militaire de saint cyr
l'école on tue une rentrée un peu
particulière
lundi 4 septembre geneviève darrieussecq
secrétaire d'état en charge des armées
est venu découvrir l'établissement le
lycée n'avait pas reçu de visite
ministérielle depuis 1966 une manière
générale la formation l'enseignement est
essentielle dans notre pays et que
l'enseignement militaire à toute sa part
nous serons pas compte suffisamment
peut-être dans le civil de l'importance
que l'armée apporte à la formation de la
jeunesse
c'est une de leurs priorités il le fonds
avait beaucoup de savoir-faire lycée
mais aussi prépas aux grandes écoles
l'établissement a développé son
enseignement supérieur
nouveauté de cette rentrée un bts
systèmes numériques option informatique
orientée sur la cyber défense c'est le
premier de ce type en france
ces 34 élèves deviendront des
techniciens capables de contrer les
cyber attaques
comment justement lutter les différents
moyens techniques pour que vous
connaissez vous avez entendu parler des
pare-feu des antivirus des et les
systèmes encore plus techniques ou
technique je dirais plus sophistiqués
pour justement détecter ces attaques
et puis les stopper et puis ensuite
oscillé les identifier parce que savoir
qui est derrière ces attaques
donc tout cela c'est c'est un métier
nous avons du retard en général et dans
le monde civil en particulier ou
n'importe quelle entreprise ou n'importe
quel smartphone est pas à l'abri d'une
attaque virale dont nous avons besoin de
jeunes formés dans ce domaine là la
visite de la secrétaire d'état s'est
terminée par un discours devant
l'ensemble de l'établissement
le premier d'une longue série pour
geneviève darrieussecq dans les
prochains mois elle prévoit de visiter
tous les lycées militaires du pays